judo is a martial art a sport a set of
techniques ideas and philosophies can we
start by uh maybe you giving a big
picture overview of what is judo to
somebody who's like outside of the whole
spectrum of grappling sports yeah judo
was originated in japan that was used as
a police tactic for self-defense and
you know subduing people it's the art of
being able to throw somebody to the
ground and hold and control the
situation
um i think it's pretty much evolved
since then though you know it's
as you include like the sport aspect of
it it's
it's grown to be something more and more
dynamic
and it's kind of gotten away from that
so the basics is
people wear something called a ghee yep
which i think
nicely mimics like outdoor clothing yep
like a jacket
and uh they start on the feet
and there's uh
they get to grip each other and the
scoring works by
the more badass the throw is the more
points you get and if uh you throw the
person big
and hard
on their back
you win the match and it's over and
that's called an e-pawn yep which is
equivalent to a knockout
so i guess there's no knock-downs
we don't count those yeah they gotta hit
their back and they gotta hit it with
force right and so there's a huge
incentive for the big throws
and uh and there's also the drama
of
somebody catching you off guard with a
surprise big throw and it's over yep
there's
there's two ways of losing really
there's the
i saw this coming
right like you just
you see it but you can't stop it
and those ones tend to be the ones you
can live with the ones that are like
really hard to live with are the ones
you never saw coming right because that
just shows that
that person has really outclassed you
right so there's like a set of a small
set of throws maybe you can go through
them that are like
you saw it coming but you couldn't do
anything about it and then there's the
set of throws that are more like
surprises so first of all the counters
or if you fake one thing and go the
other way
then that's a surprise and it's like oh
[ __ ] you off balance the person
uh because they think you're going one
way and then you go the other way and
then there's this oh [ __ ] moment all of
a sudden yeah your back is just slammed
on the ground one other one i mean
you're good of many throws but one of
them is a
that i think reveals the beauty of judo
is the foot sweep yep
there's something about the off balance
and the timing that you catch him right
all of a sudden it's like i had the same
feeling when i went skydiving like all
sudden the ground is not under you
anymore yeah and you just you go
weightlessness for like a split second
and you realize you've lost like all
control of your limbs like
it's like zero gravity right like you
just you can't turn you can't rotate you
can't do much of anything and then
before you know it you've hit the floor
yeah
it's a cool feeling when you get
thrown
um because you hope to do the same thing
to another person it's like you just hit
the ground hard because it's not you
didn't see it coming it wasn't a big
throw that got loaded up
it's like all sudden
surprise and then
like
this like feeling your back just slams
and there's like the air is out
yeah and the worst is when you get hit
twice with one throw right because
sometimes like the guy throwing you
didn't expect you to leave either so you
hit
and then that guy comes down like a
second and a half later and it's like
boom boom and then the wind is just gone
from you yeah
those are the worst and then there's the
disappointment like then the the
intellectual the cognitive part comes in
where you're like oh [ __ ] i just lost
yep and you don't have like
a connection to why
right it's almost like you've just like
you didn't literally get a concussion
like you and you understand and remember
everything but you can't figure out how
this just happened
right those are the those are the tough
ones to deal with actually have you had
moments like that where yeah where you
don't understand how it happened you
have to watch footage to understand what
happened even when you watch it you're
just like
i don't get it like why wasn't i in a
position to stop this
it makes zero sense
conceptually when you watch it you're
like
i understand how to play defense i
understand
it looks like i'm in a defensive
position but at the end of the day
i still got thrown yeah you were talking
about what is it a 2008
match
you have a
non-traditional gripping style yeah
that's accurate to say but and then you
were going against another right-handed
player and then there's some kind of
fake
that he did
and then you he caught you yep can you
can you describe the throw he caught you
with he caught me with a drop sail but
he
he kind of like we were engaged we were
looking at each other and
we were kind of at like a stalemate
right he couldn't really advance i
couldn't really advance and he kind of
just let his gaze like
wander off to the right like he was
looking at something and then i kind of
like
what's over there and then i got thrown
and it's like
so first of all uh for people don't know
uh
sayonagi drop means when you drop to
your knees and say nagi is one of the
fundamental throws of judo there's just
just a handful but does that actually
ever work
i always wondered that about like
boxing or judo
does the head movement of the person
work because we're still like kind of
dogs at heart if you look somewhere with
a dog
the dog is going to look that direction
as well does that actually work ever it
does um
but on a greater sense
what you try to do is not necessarily
get like a physical reaction of a look
but a lull of security where like
they've almost like relaxed for that
split second because you've
lured them into like a sense of comfort
and then that's when you can strike
so you have this speaking of sanagi you
have this gigantic uh standing synagogue
and um you have a specific grip one of
our challenges is there's a large number
of people that listen to the audio
version of this so we're gonna have to
try to describe some of the stuff uh
i'll do my best to try to describe with
words but uh you have you grip with your
left hand on the lapel of the jacket
or like that area yep
and uh there's kind of a lean into the
person and i suppose is there a feeling
of a lull there that you're trying to
get to where you're just it feels like
you're both calmly dancing before you
turn your hips and go in for the throw
i'm actually trying to
create
a
a sense of weightlessness for my lead
leg which would be my right leg
and
a sense of resistance from my partner
so you aren't you both kind of leaning
into each other and it creates like an
a-frame
yeah but when the a-frame is held
together at the top half which would be
my left hand and their right hand posted
on each other's chest it means our legs
are free to move and our hips are free
to move right and they're not going to
feel your leg move because of the
weightlessness and is there a feeling
like for them is there a feeling like
nothing bad can happen here we're all
relaxed everything's fine
yeah
and then they're standing off at a funny
angle and before they know it i've spun
and my back is on their chest and they
can't go anywhere yeah
yeah
you